good evening I'm very excited to be able
to present to you our speaker for this
evening and the kickoff of
sustainability weekend so we at an
energy week are extremely excited that
we've had this opportunity to partner
with sustainability weekend including
Tamara Amend who's here in the front to
put together some exceptional
programming for this sort of crossover
event and so this evening I would
actually like to welcome to the stage
Balaji Ganapathy he is the head of
workforce effectiveness and oversees the
functions of HR business consulting
diversity and inclusion corporate social
responsibility for over 335 thousand
employees of the tata consultancy
services services in north america his
primary responsibilities include
coaching sales and business teams for
business growth driving talent
management and retention initiatives
leading the corporate social
responsibility strategy and incubating a
culture of inclusion
Balaji serves as a chair of the stem
connectors STEM innovation task force
chairperson of n powers TCC Advisory
Council vice chair of the million wim
mentors will million women mentors
Leadership Council Executive Committee
of impact 2030 World Economic Forum's
education steering committee and as part
of the US Chamber of Commerce's
education employment and training
committee as head of HR for global R&D
he's part of Tatas corporate technology
board with a mandate for
institutionalizing a culture of
innovation across the organization which
makes him the perfect guest speaker
based on sustainability weekend's themes
of equity diversity and sustainability
inclusion as team of as head of HR 40
CSS corporate Learning Center he led a
team responsible for onboarding and
integrating over 12,000 campus hires I
am very pleased to welcome
Balaji to the stage
thank you good evening everybody
it's happy all right so very happy to be
here and thanks to Carnegie Mellon for
inviting me to speak to you and share
them some of my thoughts and
perspectives about equity diversity
inclusion and a few other things I hope
you'll have questions because I have
prepared for half an hour and I hope the
rest of the time we'll spend in
interacting with each other a couple of
things I thought of and I was sitting
here watching these young upcoming
professionals come up and present on
stage and share their concepts it took
me back 20 years when I did the same and
it's really invigorating to be an
entrepreneur and have amazing concepts
that can change the world mine was on a
fuel cell powered car which you know
goes and very well aligned with the
theme of clean energy and reducing
energy consumption overall but some of
the things that I learned during that
time stay with me even today 2025 years
later the second thing I want to mention
before I kick off my session is the
great relationship between TCS and CMU
very thankful for this partnership this
amazing partnership two years ago TCS
made a 35 million dollar endowment to
CMU and as a result of that is starting
to see the vibrant innovation that's
going to happen around the areas of
robotics or dorama systems and
artificial intelligence and so many
other digital technologies that are
powering today's economy and that's
going to be the how I'm going to frame
my session and talk about education
as really a great lever for Economic
Opportunity and the role of digital
technologies within that that's what I'm
here to share the message around so when
I entered the workforce I in fact I was
an entrepreneur before I joined TCS so
when I entered the workforce the kind of
things that were being talked about
where email having you know access to
email itself was a great thing having
access to a computer to do something was
even better and technology meant
something else in today's world
technology means something incredibly
different right you think about what has
happened over the past two three decades
in terms of the proliferation of
Technology and also the rate at which it
has been adopted and commercialized for
business good as well as societal good
it's incredible so we live in a time
where we are able to use buzzwords like
big data and analytics and Internet of
Things
it just doesn't stay as a buzzword it's
actually practically applicable very
much approachable and accessible to
people to create innovations around and
commercialize it and also use it for
social good so we live in a very
interesting time so what does the future
look like the future is here and now is
my first message to you and that's
evident in the kind of presentations
that you saw from the upcoming
researchers and undergraduate master
students at CMU and other universities
who are represented here they've brought
the best of innovation and applied that
into social problems that they saw
around them but the future is here and
now also because like I said these are
not buzzwords these are technologies
that are powering solutions within
enterprises within countries within
and when I think about the resurgence of
a city like Pittsburgh you can certainly
say that a lot of this has to do with
the technology uplift that has happened
right so so the future is here and now
that's my first message to you and when
you think about the opportunities that
lie ahead there's tremendous
possibilities that are there for us to
really harness and utilize the potential
of so some of you will be familiar with
the concept of the fourth Industrial
Revolution and what that means and for
those who have heard of it but want to
understand more I have a short video to
play
now okay that's fine I'll do a
one-minute summary of that the fourth
Industrial Revolution is basically
following the first three the first
three many of you may be familiar with
but the use of steam to really drive a
production and productivity was the
first Industrial Revolution the Second
Industrial Revolution was the use of
electricity to commercialize and then
again increase productivity but bring in
some mechanization and machine ization
into society and the third Industrial
Revolution is all about computers and
information technology and the ability
of those technologies to then again
enhance societal growth and productivity
right what is happening today is that we
are in the early stages of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and what is so
different between this particular
innovation cycle which is known as the
fourth Industrial Revolution and others
is that it is happening in a space where
three different areas intersecting right
you have technology that is in the is in
does it intersecting with nature and
biology and also systems so you have
three different elements coming together
and the opportunities that then become
available
for the kind of innovation that hi can
happen is completely different so that's
what you're seeing in rapid advances for
example in drug discovery Bionic calms
you on the other side you're seeing
rapid advances in things like autonomous
vehicles and what it can do
UAVs and yesterday I was reading about
the success of a small start-up not
small anymore a startup called
zipline that's using drones to deliver
blood to people in Rwanda right so the
availability of these technologies and
what it's doing is flipping them the
whole innovation model upside down right
so as an organization let me shift gears
and think about it from an organized
perspective right as an organization
water said that we do in order to you
know really harness the power of these
technologies that's what I want to spend
a few minutes on and then that will lead
to my next session next part of the
session which is more around what does
that mean for society at large and what
role do each of us have to play within
that right so we from a company
perspective we look at this and the way
our thought leadership framework is laid
out we call it as business for auto and
business for our toe is all about we are
a b2b company a technology company
that's providing digital services to
Fortune hundred watching thousand
companies around the world
right so when we view it what we are
seeing is that these technologies are
helping us take our customers who are
enterprises be more intelligent agile
automated and on the cloud and what is
behind each of those four technology LED
innovations intelligent means having not
just access to data but converting that
data into insights and using analytics
to lead us to data base and
evidence-based approaches to decision
making right
that's what being intelligent
Enterprises is all about being agile
means able to move away from an
innovation cycle where you had to wait
for months and years to see technology
lead change happen and be able to do it
in incremental incremental E as you grow
your enterprise right and so for those
of you who have been on the corporate
side you can understand the challenges
involved in technology projects right
these are never on time never on budget
and by the time you get to the point
where the software system is implemented
its need has already gone I see somebody
smiling in the audience yeah you
you felt the pain you've seen it happen
but what the agile based methodologies
allow us to do is to cut through all of
that and basically interact directly
between people who are owning the
product to people who are designing the
product right so that's the second
technological innovation that we are
tapping into the third one is being
automated which means that the resources
that are available within the
organization can then be prioritized to
something bigger than what it is
currently dedicated whether it is human
resources technology resources
intellectual resources financial
resources you can do that if you think
of it from a machine first delivery
model which is what we bring to the
table as an organization and there are
ramifications of that but the fourth
element of it is cloud and again many of
you are familiar with these technologies
whether it is public cloud private cloud
hybrid clouds and the ability for you to
be accessing data real time in places
where you know that the resilience of
that data when any external interactions
happen is very high right so it's it's
transformative not just for large
enterprises it's also transformative for
small and medium businesses and to be
able to do that
think of the move to cloud as how we
dealt with y2k and what happened during
that time right and the the model of
having a factory based approach to
looking at what systems existed and
moving them and migrating them into new
set of systems that's what's happening
today with the move to cloud of course
cloud has much more potential than that
but the early adoption of cloud is
happening in the space so if these are
the four technology innovations or
technology drivers behind business for
r2 there are four behavioral elements
which hasn't changed since the first
Industrial Revolution it continues to
remain the same
but the very interpret and use it has
changed over time so if you look at it
today mass customization are tailoring
it to the segment of one this has always
been the case if you look at 20 30 years
ago businesses where again all about
putting the customer at the center of
everything that you do right so it's not
very different but what has happened
today is because of the availability of
these technologies you are able to make
that kind of customization and
personalization in a seamless manner in
a more cost-effective manner
in a manner where you can play around
and scale things pretty quickly in a
manner where you are able to see results
and the feedback loop is much faster
right so mass customization and this for
example if you look at what's happening
with retail and the whole shopping
experience or with travel and how you
interact with air travel or when you go
on a cruise all of that is one of the
first few adoptions and manifestations
of mass customization the second aspect
is creating exponential value which
means that using the limited resources
or the resources that are available to
have a multiplier effect and that's what
is the second concept again something
very linked to productivity but in this
is not just about productivity this is
about growth and transformation and
that's what thinking about it from a
exponential value perspective brings him
right so the exponential value to larges
lines of business within customers but
the entire enterprise right and the
third element is leveraging ecosystem so
today you're collaborating across
functions and when I when I first
learned about this and a couple of days
ago when I heard the introductory speech
by your president
he mentioned the word interdisciplinary
and I think that's where liberating
ecosystems comes into play because you
are no longer siloed within the
boundaries of a discipline or a unit or
a business line but you are actually
liberating ecosystems not just within
your organization but we have a co
innovation Network where we have
researchers we have startups we have
academic institutions research
institutions all of that that you can
tap into as you are thinking about
innovating a new product or a service or
an offering right so and these
ecosystems are tremendous if you are
able to tap into for example public
infrastructure systems and have that
interact with data that you have within
your organization and create something
of value for a town or a community think
of what it can do right so earlier you
could imagine that but you couldn't
deliver it because the constraints that
were placed by the technological
challenges today you don't have that
anymore right
so the fourth element is embracing risk
and this is all about our journey as an
organization to reinvent ourselves every
few years or every few decades we've
been in businesses the fiftieth year of
existence and if you meet people who
have been 20 30 years in the company
offices there are a lot you ask them how
was how are things when you started with
the company you get tremendous stories
that that that didn't bring a lot of
historical perspective of the change
that happens within organizations
technology companies in information
technology companies and where we are
today so this the embracing risk is also
about being able to channel those
thoughts and culture to help our
customers also embrace that risk but do
that in a way that's very diligent right
they're able to embrace that risk pilot
new ideas new technologies new offerings
which you can see an immediate effect on
the customer side also
and this is happening all around the
world this is not just isolated in the
US this is happening Europe UK companies
around the world are doing this right
so in summary all of this can happen
only if we harness the abundance that is
in the middle of this whole new
ecosystem an abundance means from our
point of view abundance of talent and
abundance of opportunities right as the
company but when I if I now shift focus
and look at the abundance that is
available around us in the world and
wear that hat it's amazing we keep
thinking about the challenges that we
face as a society three billion people
employed again seven billion citizens
around the world and if you look at the
UN sustainable development goals that
will give you a gold sheet of how the
world can become a better place right 17
goals that speak to the challenges that
exist around the world but the resources
are also available on the other side
right so whether it is talent whether it
is technology whether it is access to
better infrastructure better thought
process better so many things have
changed so in that context if I think
about a person living today and have
wanting to participate in this new
economy in this new fourth Industrial
Revolution economy there is a bridge
that we need to put in place and the
bridge is needed because the way our
education systems and society has
prepared people over the past 100 plus
years to participate with veteran
organizations or be entrepreneurs and
business people on their own that's not
going to work anymore
it worked really well
for
and agrarian era it worked in a pretty
good way for the industrial era but the
demands that are being placed on young
people as they come up through life very
different today I look at my own
daughter and I wonder you know at the
day when she's gonna ask the question
that I have
I can't Google up right it's gonna
happen someday because kids are much
more smarter they have access to more
information they fail fast fail early
early on in their life so they are
learning resilience and how to learn and
they're coming up with all of these kind
of mindsets in order to face the world
but if we corner them or if we put them
into a system that is not meant to
provide the kind of experiences that is
required to participate in the new
economy that is a challenge right so
that's something that all of us have to
think about and this is not to say any
system is good or bad it is what it is
today even more what worries me is that
the people who are not participating in
the economies of trading right if you
are here in the room we are really
privileged to be part of that society
where we know what our roles are what we
could do well and be doing this think of
the underserved and underrepresented
parts of society where today they don't
have access to these opportunities
because the education and the awareness
that is required for people to get there
it's not there today right to think of
that for a moment and think of how we
can advance that so that's what I'm
going to spend the next few minutes
talking about and I want to start with
three metrics for you to frame this
problem right one is that if you look at
the world of today this was a statistic
that is from three years ago still
through today 35 percent of core skills
that are required in career
and opportunities of 2020 are changing
during a five-year period which means
that this is our world changing from
under our feet what was my first message
the future is here and now and it's
happening for people who are employed of
people who are entrepreneurs who are
doing these businesses the way they have
to interact with organizations the way
how they have to think about innovation
commercialization all of that has
changed and it's changing rapidly so as
an organization there are some
responsibilities that we have as society
there are some responsibilities that we
have to understand what these changes
are and make sure that these are signals
that are passed on from the world of
work to the world of Education and
beyond I agree the second statistic is
that 65% of students who are entering
primary school today are going to be in
jobs that do not exist yet how do you
prepare a world where you don't know
what the jobs of the future are going to
look like and believe me these kids who
are participating these opportunities
they know where to go they know how to
go but as society if we look at it in
scale and the disparate systems that
exist across countries and across
continents then the problem that we're
dealing with is totally different right
so not only do we have to envisage the
future and understand what is what what
that win is going to look like we then
have to translate it backwards to how
this is unfold and what can we do today
that can prepare people for that future
tomorrow right and the third element
I'll put in front of you the third
statistic to frame this problem is that
I mentioned earlier that technology also
with some challenges right and many of
us have seen and heard the doomsday
scenarios of millions of jobs going to
be lost because of automation and new
technology adoption but I don't
subscribe to that view entirely the
thing the element of truth that is there
there are two elements of truth one is
that what we call as a job is going to
change so the skills that are required
while some may remain and some part of
that work will remain some part of that
work will go away and as you can imagine
it is going to be the mundane and the
repetitive aspects of what we do today
in our jobs that is going to change but
as a result of that there are going to
be some work streams some career paths
some jobs that will disappear and that's
been the case with every Industrial
Revolution that's happened the second
element of truth which is troubling is
that if you are a woman or if you are a
person from a minority background the
impact on you is going to be much higher
and that's where the burden of what is
going to happen is going to fall on
those who already don't have what it the
kind of support that is needed or the
opportunities that are needed right but
even with all of that I believe that we
have a great future ahead of us because
I don't believe that machines are going
to take over I believe that it's going
to be the people like you and me who are
going to determine where our world hits
next of course that means that we need
to be responsible we need to think about
what kind of boundaries we put around
how we innovate and doing it in a way
that is not just fair and just but also
he could about right so how are we doing
that and what what kind of thoughts can
I bring to the table from the
experiences that we have had as an
organization
to bring to this discussion and then I
will open it up for questions and
interaction on what other ideas we could
have so as a company with 380,000
employees around the world we have a few
things that work really well for us it
is the talent and the abundance of
talent that is the starting point so
rather than look at this as a problem of
you know do we need these many employees
what's going to happen it implies in the
future we looked at it as an opportunity
to prepare the same set of employees for
a new tomorrow the second thing is
130,000 employees are women against a
sector where the representation is about
twenty four percent today in the u.s.
most good companies are doing a
twenty-two percent in the tech sector
that's no great shakes but you need to
do better you need to create more
pathways which I'll address in a
subsequence like 133 nationalities which
means that the cultural competencies
that are required in the world of work
of tomorrow we have that in abundance
and 50 markets so market knowledge also
we have in abundance so that's what we
look at as our strengths as an
organization so if you view your own
personal strengths in the context of
where we are and where we are going
that's a good starting point then what
do you do with it this is just a summary
2.2 million people have been reached
through the work that we're doing over
the past few years and we've invested
close to 200 million dollars in societal
initiatives but even more important is
that we're doing walking the talk within
the organization also over five hundred
thousand half a million new digital
competencies that we had developed just
in the past couple of years and over a
million certifications what does that
mean it means if I framed the problem I
knew I was going to come up with some
solution also to offer the solution that
we have to offer is
that in the world of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and using business
for auto as a thought leadership
framework we believe that we can harness
abundance to empower communities that is
our worldview and how do we do that we
do that in three ways you can do that by
starting within your organization's
rescaling and upskilling employees so
that they can participate in the world
of today and tomorrow
preparing young people for opportunities
and that means interacting with
education and social systems that exists
here and around the world the third of
the most important thing is making sure
that all of this is done with a lens of
equity and access so that the people
that we are trying to reach and impact
first are the ones who are getting at
least today okay with me so far
now now I'm gonna give you some examples
of how we're doing it and hopefully that
will give you some food for thought and
also something to reflect on as we get
into the discussion part of this session
we bring building cross-functional to
skills you know when the title of the
session is transdisciplinary education
I'm sure you know I'm gonna walk the
talk when it comes to that from the
organization's side see if you view it
as a triangle what we are saying is that
what we are channeling to our employees
and to customer executives who are
talking to us also what we are saying is
that in the new world of work you need
knowledge deep knowledge from a
technical sense deep knowledge from a
domain sense and deep knowledge from a
contextual sense knowledge of Technology
is something you can easily gain by
going to a course gaining a
certification knowledge of domain is
something you gain not just by attending
a course by work working in a say for
example an energy company you gain
domain knowledge right but the third
element which is the power of your
existing workforce and people who are
already at work is the contextual
knowledge of how to do what to do and
all of this coming together is what is
powering the business for our journey
that we're having and that means giving
people access to educational and
training opportunities where they are
when they want so if I go from here to
my hotel in Pittsburgh this evening and
it takes 15 minutes what can I learn
that is bite-sized and that's useful for
me I open up my phone I have a fresco
play app which is tool that TCS uses i
scroll down to machine learning that
sounds interesting everybody seems to be
talking about it nowadays so what does
that mean
and 15 minutes I can gain basic
knowledge of what that is and that tells
me whether this is something that I have
aptitude for something I want to pursue
further and then I graduate to the next
level by signing up for a course it can
be a web-based course it can be a
virtual one or I can attend it in an
external forum so providing layers
opportunity for layers of competencies
and skills to be gained is how we are
breaking this down and democratizing it
basically you're democratizing both
access to these opportunities as well as
proficiency how you gain proficiency in
these skills and competencies so that's
the first part the second part when it
comes to external and now the rest of my
session is all going to be about
externally what we do in the community
and how we can interact through
probabilitor public/private partnerships
and other means it's all about three
things context which if you remember I
said is the most important aspect
content and connection that's in summary
what we do with the
external world in terms of community
engagement and some examples of how we
do that is what I'm going to describe to
you the first one is go IT couldn't be
more happier passionate about a program
than gooid this is next year is our
tenth year of running this program this
is in summary a program that helps young
people and people from disadvantaged and
underrepresented backgrounds and
under-resourced parts the society to
stop being just consumers of technology
and start being creators and innovators
of technology how do you do that very
simply translating what you saw before
this in terms of the wonderful
presentations and concepts that many of
your teams brought up here and showed
and translating it to a k-12 environment
that's pretty much it why because some
of you who are you know here in the room
still know the passion and what it comes
with when you the Eureka moment that
occurs when you are able to see yourself
using something that you learned to
solve a problem that is persisting
that's what go IT does we help students
define a problem that they see around
them or if they cannot we offer them one
from what we have seen in the community
or nationally and then put them in teams
and first of all start with empathy if
you look at what the World Economic
Forum said is going to be one of the top
skills for 2020 how many have you seen
if you've not seen that you should go
and look at that the tops one of the top
skills is emotional intelligence right
starts with empathy being able to relate
and put yourself in the shoes of
somebody else doing those that problem
but then being able to sucess
and see how you can address that starts
with that then goes into human centered
design so we teach them design thinking
and we have narrowed it and we have you
know really being able to abstract it to
a way where within 20 hours these
students are able to absorb these
concepts apply them on a problem of
their choice come up with solutions
present those solutions and then get
excited about working on it after we
leave this with inner-city neighborhoods
and rural parts of the country where let
alone a technology course or something
around computer science many of those
school systems don't even have the
resources that are needed to do that so
that's where you can have transformative
change when you apply something that you
know can work really well but really
hone how it can do well in a place where
the need is the most so the whole
innovation process that happens within
go IT is mimicking what we do if you
remember the for technology leave us
with in business for darto agile was one
of them this is mimicking the agile
methodology that we use within the
organization so they come up with
concepts wireframes storyboards quickly
program and see how that solution comes
to life using technology and then get
feedback immediately so that they can
iterate and improve upon those and
that's what they do in New York region
this is run in 58 cities across u.s. and
Canada and has grown to many countries
outside of the US and Canada as well
today
in the New York Region we decided to use
the platform that we have as the title
sponsor of the New York City Marathon to
bring some of these kids and share the
concepts that they had similar to have
some of you shared
in front of an esteemed audience we
asked them to think about problems
around health around wellness around
nutrition the five boroughs and a few
cities outside of New York City and
asked them to come up and pitch this in
front of CEOs of healthcare
organizations of companies that are
involved in running and led runners
themselves let's see how they did
we'll play the video
[Music]
yes
these kids were brought together through
TTS is Bill IT a program that encourages
students to pursue stem degrees the end
game now is just to inspire students and
in computer science specifically shows
and that they can be producers of the
big things everyday not just consumers
my dad
it can help me to go today by not making
my neck because my teachers say the
[Music]
so that's just an example of what you
can do by bringing industry context and
pairing up mentors with young kids this
particular team was from the Bronx but
there were teams from across all the
boroughs that competed in this challenge
but the idea is not just to provide the
challenge and the opportunity for people
to engage but to provide that real-world
connect right that gives the context
they're able to say that ok this is not
just something that I'm learning to
write a test this is something that I'm
going to use this is going to stay with
me for life problem-solving skills the
communication skills the team-building
skills and you ask me as an employer
what is lacking in in you know that I
would like to fix among people that we
hire it is those skills you ask any
employer around the world at least 70 80
percent of the time will get the same
answer so providing that context puts
them on a path where even if you are not
there they cannot stop thinking about
how they can apply these concepts that
they have learned these techniques that
they have learned to problems that they
see around them so it develops a way of
thinking now the second example I want
to share with you is ignite my future in
school and this was born out of the need
that exists across America that many of
you may be aware of many of you may not
be aware of we are sitting of course
here in CMU which boasts being the top
computer science school in the country
and possibly the world
but do you know that less than 20% of
schools across America
even access to a computer science course
less than a million out of the 55
million students in our public education
system or even being offered something
that you can refer to as a computation
computational thinking or computer
science concepts yet as employers as
industry we predict that computational
thinking not just computer science
computer science is the ultimate
reflection of that but if you look at
the breadth of skills that are needed
computational thinking is going to be a
foundational skill required for any job
any carrier any sector why because it is
the new problem-solving methodology of
the 21st century it's not that it is new
in terms of a concept and a science it's
been in existence for many years now but
it's capturing the public imagination
because it is giving a way for us to
define this and say that in order to
interact with machines in order to
interact with these things that we are
creating you need to know how to talk to
it right you need to know how to look at
data how to make sense of it how to
abstract it how to model the data and
these are not just needed if you are a
computer scientist or a computer science
engineer these are problem-solving
skills that you need as a citizen of the
world of today and tomorrow only then
will you be able to appreciate what's
happening around us and how these
digital technologies are impacting you
right so we said how do we go about
doing this how do we go about bringing
computational thinking in an ecosystem
where computer science itself has a
challenging presence so many years for
many years we've been working with
efforts like cs4 all
and other national and regional efforts
to advance computer science education
working with senators and Congress
persons at the hill to promote policy
that will allow for computer science to
be introduced into high schools in the
middle schools the move needle is moving
but it is moving really slowly we don't
have time for that as a country as a
society because the students who are
coming out of the education system today
need it as much as when the policy comes
into effect maybe a few years from now
so it is up to us as citizens as
industry as garment as educational
institutions as civic society to take up
and take charge of this so one solution
that we offered for that is to partner
with a reputable educational
organization called Discovery Education
he said let's develop a program that
brings computational thinking into the
classroom but the difference is that
we're not gonna ask teachers to do
something new we're not going to ask
teachers to change their entire
curriculum you're not going to ask them
to do one more thing because if there is
any group of people in the country that
are underappreciated it is the teachers
they are carrying the weight of systemic
challenges that has plagued the system
so how do we make them ambassadors of
this new approach how do we empower them
that was the thought process so we
developed a set of resources that will
bring computational thinking into core
subjects so that whether you're teaching
math science arts humanities English
language any subject that you are
teaching as a teacher there are 3.5
million of those across the country any
subject you can today teach
computational thinking using these
lesson plans using these resources what
does that do it creates an opportunity
for
people do not feel isolated and be left
out not thing that they want the best if
anybody wants the best for our students
it is the teachers because the parents
are there
we have biased right we gave birth to
them it's the teachers for doing it
altruistically so how about empowering
them and so what we did is we developed
these resources and lesson plans there
are 40 of these today available on
ignite my future dot o-r-g ignite my
future in school dot o-r-g I am sorry
and what you can do as a teacher is gain
access to any one of these lesson plans
and use it in the classroom but we said
okay you can't build it and expect
people to use it so we also launched a
grass root level effort where we are now
partnering with ten pilot districts
across the country to bring this to a
school and the entire school district
some of the early adopters include the
Dallas Independent School District
Harrisburg Pennsylvania with Janesville
Wisconsin New York City there are three
districts that are adopting it Charlotte
North Carolina I can name places across
the country that are saying that this
opportunity is something that we have to
make yourself and so teachers get a full
day of professional development so they
are not just getting a chance to
understand this new concepts and how
they can use it in the classroom because
it's by choice no one is mandating them
no one is going to tell them that if you
don't use this something's gonna happen
this is by choice but when you do that
can you help them plan their lessons
plan their weeks plan their pedagogy in
such a way that it makes it easy and
accessible for them to do it and that's
what that day does and then at the end
of the day we bring in parents and
members of the community for a community
night where they can see the
of these concepts in action they see
drones and robos and other things
interact with them but then they get to
do some family exercises which
demystifies that so curriculum and
courses and resources professional
development and through partnerships and
community nights that act as that lever
for change in the in the local
communities and yesterday we had the
opportunity to talk to our friends at
CME and hopefully the program will come
to Pittsburgh and to the school systems
here and around Pennsylvania also in the
near future we hope we committed to do
that these lessons plans as I said are
available if you have a teacher who
wants to make use of this please contact
us through the website there are
certification modules also available so
if you want to learn about the seven
foundational principles behind
computational thinking even for you I
found it pretty interesting to refresh
those concepts you can go there you can
view it it's all self-paced modules with
pre and post surveys to help you gauge
how much you have learned but if you are
a teacher wanting to use this in the
classroom that's not it that's not all
that we're doing we're having learning
leaders and a network and a community of
leaders be created so that both in the
location that they are internationally
they are part of a larger community okay
most of us are familiar with social
networks but for teachers it makes a
huge difference because if they hear
from another teacher what they did and
how it worked the contextual knowledge
of how they can apply it comes about and
that's what we're doing through those
learning leaders and through those
networks so couldn't be happier with
this partnership we launched it with a
goal and a vision to reach a million
students in five years and 20,000
teachers sounded ambitious he started in
this school year
17 September we've already reached 2,500
plus teachers and 150,000 students so we
believe that this is something that's
really powerful that can change the way
in which people learn in a
transdisciplinary way so not as silos of
math and science and arts and humanities
but use computational thinking as a
common framework to bring all of this
together and I and you know there are
some impact measurements also if you are
interested in that I'm happy to talk
about it as on in the Q&A part now for a
video of how this is working in the
Dallas school system
[Music]
to be at this first day of discovery and
really see ignite my future come to life
is one of those moments where I'm so
grateful through the work that I do the
careers of the future are changing
almost faster than we can keep up with
them and it's exciting for our children
and we're excited for them and we want
to do as much as we can to help them not
only be prepared to be amazing human
beings but also to be agile in the
workforce and to have lots of really
cool skills to pull from we are going to
set the stage for this country around
this I think
we have to do this where the country is
going the world is going we really have
to give our students this opportunity
and the way that we do it is we teach
our teachers this will be something
really transformative and if anything I
think the kids will come back and say
finally like I can really show you what
I can do I can show you what I know you
let me do something that I feel like I'm
really good at that can really
articulate the knowledge that you have
given you you know a lot of times people
said let's get our kids ready for 21st
century skills or get that we're heading
to the 22nd century now and the more
that we can expose them to the
methodology and thinking the process
behind it the easier it is for them to
apply it to different mediums the
challenges we face as human beings on
planet Earth today really do require
creative collaborative adaptable
solutions we want to celebrate when
you're doing in the classroom and most
importantly we want you to be able to
share that celebration with other
teachers I think it's a good way to open
up channels of communication that
haven't been previously explored and the
whole idea of a sense of community if we
can have more of an online community
then we can be working more
collaboratively the gate is opening like
someone has taken the key and let you
out of the cage to take off for an NAC
where you wind up back in the day we
needed to prepare our kids to play
jeopardy now we need to having the rifle
questions so I just say hats off
tremendous thank you to talk to em to
discovery for actually investing in
American education and what we're trying
to do and really having us just think
larger think bigger think boulder think
grander in five years these kids are
gonna say thank you for teaching me how
to think
[Music]
the last part I want to mention is that
content and context is not enough you
need to have connections so that once
they have the knowledge of how to use
these skills have the right kind of
foundational skills be available not
just through after-school and all the
school experiences but within the school
system itself you also need to connect
to carriers of today and tomorrow and
that's where what we've been engaged in
is to power the technology
infrastructure as well as create grass
root level efforts along with partners
from industry and from the other power
of the sectors of society and again
these are efforts that span across the
country across all regions across all
demographics but three specific
initiators I want to mention is oneness
million women mentors which is an effort
to help advance girls and young women in
STEM disciplines and careers and again
here the metrics are pretty ominous the
wage gap is real the education gap is
even more real right so how do you build
bridges and opportunities and that's
what this particular effort is doing
both through grass root level efforts
where companies are identifying mentors
who can engage with young girls and
women but also as these young women into
the workforce the statistic also says
that 50% of the drop-off within the stem
workforce for women happens in the first
ten years so what do you do to improve
persistence
how can you pair them up with internal
mentors within the organization sponsors
who can help them at once so those are
all efforts that are going on happy to
share that when we started we wanted to
reach a million that was we started in
2015 and by 2017 we had crossed that
million today we are at 2 million
pledges for mentors and mentees
for this effort and we already crossed 1
million actual mentor-mentee engagements
that have been reported across the
country so again very much
aspirational scale effort to bring this
to attention and engage from an industry
perspective the second one is us 2020
which is a again effort that is built
around students of colors and students
from minority groups but high impact
mentoring so you're looking at a city
like say for example Boston or Chicago
or even smaller towns and seeing what is
the baseline for stem mentoring that
exist today how do you grow that how do
we do that in partnership with smaller
organizations that understand the
problems and are best suited to find
solutions to it and that's what's
happening with this effort about what 17
cities across the country are involved
in it every year with the previous
administration every year we were giving
out stem mentoring or Watts at the White
House hoping to continue that with this
new administration as well
empower is the final one I want to
mention disadvantaged youth so if you
are looking at the early part of the
system the middle part of the system if
you look at disadvantaged youth which is
between eighteen and twenty-four and
unemployed right there are a lot of
those youth also in the country that
need to be addressed and which is what
this organization called empower is
doing they are headquartered out of New
York but have operations across multiple
cities in the country and the focus is
to have a 22-week curriculum that can
help provide technology skills that make
them employable that's the crux of it
but the focus is on disadvantaged youth
and veterans so those are the three
examples they wanted to share with you I
want to summarize this whole session by
starting where we started that the
future is here and now which means that
we need to act at the pace of innovation
not at the regular pace that we have
been at so if we have to increase our
pace we need to have sustainable
solutions but scalable solutions also
and it is possible if it
if a company like us with our partners
can do it with your brainpower and the
knowledge and wisdom that you have we
can do so much more right but it needs
us to really come together to cross
boundaries and sit together to look at
these solutions and think of scale and
impact and sustainability at the get-go
not start the effort and then do that
later which I thought was well
represented in many of your students
concentrations they thought about where
this is going a few years from now had
the same mentality is what we need in
these social efforts the second is
providing education whether it is in
college school or in general because you
don't stop learning just because you're
not attending this school right so in
general lifelong learning as a mentality
as the culture means access to education
that is of course it has to be fun and
engaging but also that is relevant
relevant to the need of today and
tomorrow and that is contextual
investing in building resilient
populations so cities like Pittsburgh
communities need to look at where they
are today the jobs disappearing will
happen in some communities but we can't
fight it alone we have to come together
and think of how do you build resilience
and skills and access to skills and in a
good education contextual relevant
education can make that difference so we
need to think of that and look at
multi-year efforts to advance that and
finally I want to end with the
positivity that they said you know I am
extremely a beat about the future
because it is humans are going to
control what happens next and if we can
harness this abundance we can
democratize prosperity every person can
have access to opportunities if you
really put our minds against it and do
it in a collaborative manner and that's
what I want to share with you thank you
for being with me and sharing these
thoughts I look forward to hearing your
questions thank you
we have an app that where we've been
collecting questions throughout the
session so we'll just do a couple of
them the good news is that we have a
reception immediately following and so
folks can talk with you directly and ask
you some additional questions like that
so the first question is someone just
wants to thank you and TCS for the
incredible support of CMU both students
and faculty can embracing risk and
change be incentivized in large
operations that's a good point and this
is where everybody wants to change but
everybody wants change but nobody wants
to change right so incentives and
culture are so important this is what I
learned
part of my bio involved being the head
of HR for our CTO and R&D group and
researchers as you can imagine are ones
who are you know have a methodical
process a scientific approach to things
but not always the best at
commercializing ideas right so doing
research for research and advancing that
field used to be what our organization
also was focused on but through an
effort where we created bridges between
the research and the business
applicability of that we were able to
you know create a change and create a
culture where innovation incentivizing
innovation became the theme so you have
to make big bets but you have to look at
who your current audiences and embracing
risk means that you create those sort of
conditions that make it easy for people
to embrace risk if you performance
management systems or your appraisal
systems are going to ding you if you
fail then you're not going to have a
culture where people feel free to
embrace that risk so you have to have
the right kind of culture right kind of
behaviors and incentivize those through
your actions another question that we do
have some good questions
with its strong IT background and
heritage how will TCS participate in the
advanced robotics business so we of
course view ourselves as a services
organization that powers other
organizations and their effort so it's
primarily going to be collaborative in
nature and even today some of the
advanced robotics whether it is in the
automobile sector or in the energy
sector or in oil and gas we are doing a
lot of efforts that I can't talk about
because of client confidentiality but we
are certainly right there so it is our
space will be where we can help our
customers reimagine how to move from
where they are today to adopt these
technologies and then bring it to their
customers there in consumer so that's
the space that we're gonna continue
operating in but I wish I'm looking
forward to a day when a robo will run
the New York City Marathon so that's
that's something you know I'm looking
forward to and so let's have one last
question can you tell us what as
University students we should be
thinking about what's a number one
message you'd like to leave us with stay
grounded
so somebody every time I meet someone
and I'm having this pin I get asked this
question what is this about this is the
United Nations sustainable development
goals why do I wear it because it gives
me perspective I think as students are
as individuals participating in society
that's all we need we need somebody to
remind ourselves that we are not the
world but we can help advance the world
so staying grounded having perspective
is the starting point and then the rest
of it will follow thank you thank you
all
so with that we actually are going to
conclude energy week for this week for
2018 we are planning energy week for
2019 already OB March 25 through 29
today we look forward to seeing you in
the future but from all of us the the
team Amanda and J Whittaker and all of
us at the Scott Institute we want to
thank you for being with us this week
for those of you who are staying for
sustainability weekend we look forward
to seeing you tomorrow but otherwise
thank you very much we'll talk soon on
the other side of that wall which is our
reception thank you
[Applause]
I guess we get all the chords and
everything right this is mine this is
Amanda